foreign
let's go to
um Stacy in Bryan Texas what's up Stacy
hi John how are you I'm great what's
going on
um
doing good so far
um we're just kind of ready to jump into
this question and see if you can kind of
give me some insights all right let's do
it Jump On In
all right um so I will preface this with
me and my husband are definitely just in
a crazy season of life right now and
we've had a lot of
um chaos going in on our work lives we
have a four-year-old who has had some
developmental delays a lot of chasing
um evaluations Specialists therapies
things like that and because that wasn't
crazy enough we're also due with our
next one any day now all right
all right
and so now more than ever I really think
finding time for he and I can to connect
is really important but I'm having a
hard time being able to felt healthy
expectations and boundaries around us
spending quality time because we don't
like doing a lot of the same things like
we're just we're very different when it
comes to our interest in trying to find
ways that we can both enjoy things we
like and share experiences with each
other when
um like I said we just don't really want
to sort of like doing the same things
so is your concern this picture that you
have in your head of this is what I
thought this was going to look like
or is it actual
like I really miss my husband
and you get the difference there in that
question
I do and uh it's probably the second one
okay
so it sounds like
the
the question you asked like how how do
we deal with expectations and how do we
like find things that we can do in
common together that's secondary too
I really miss this guy
yes
have you told them that
um I feel like I've tried okay
but I also think he struggles with the
sometimes with some of the emotions
involved in that and being able to
really sit down and be vulnerable with
me
and so it's almost like to sit down and
try and have that conversation and
sometimes I feel like he's just doing
the headlights
I I assure you he is 100 percent
100 he's deer in headlights and he
doesn't want to say the wrong thing and
he doesn't want to do the wrong thing
and I I can just speak to my my life
um
I when we were expecting a second I I I
I was busy my wife was busy we had a
little one
I knew I was good at playing guitar
and I could get better at that so I just
started gravitating more towards that
and I knew I was good at work so I just
started working more and whenever a cool
crazy chaotic
punk rock showed go to town I'd just go
to that because I knew I would have fun
there you see what I'm saying it was
never an attempt to get away from my
wife ever it was always just a I know
I'm good over here because I'm clearly
not good over here
and that just was a matter of me not
having the tools and my wife didn't have
the tools and so we just were went and
did the things that we knew how to do
it's like my car breaking down the side
of the road and I don't know how to fix
the tires I can change the oil and so I
would just get busy changing the oil on
the side of the road and then I get done
and the oil is perfectly changed and the
car still can't drive because there's no
tires are all flat right that's what's
happening here
um
when's your baby due
um in a matter of
about a month and a half or so okay very
cool
so give me an example of a way you've
tried to tell him I miss you
um you know I I really think I've
you know with you working so much and I
want to be more intentional about
finding time for us
um
and you know just trying to say like you
know like hey I want to spend time with
you before you know we just kind of
enter even more chaos and
I mean I haven't exactly outright said
that I miss them because
I knew you hadn't said that okay here's
a here's a new way I want to reframe
this and it's what you're doing here is
you're gonna
um you're speaking Spanish and he's
speaking Italian and I'm gonna teach you
how to speak Italian for him okay okay
when you go to a guy a young dad
and I'll just Brian was just north of
where I grew up so
um or I guess it's West where I grew up
when you tell a young Texas dad who's
working 80 hours a week and his wife is
pregnant with number two
um
I just you're working so much and you're
never here
what he hears is he's experiencing the
house is on fire
and you want to talk about how warm it
is
and he's just trying to save everybody
and the only way he knows to save people
is by making money
being successful in his job okay so
here's a different way
should you invite him out
I don't want you to have a blank sheet
of paper in front of him
and what we're going to do is we're not
going to use amorphous ethereal language
like I just feel like we're not gonna do
that
we're going to speak his language and
we're going to say all right what I want
to do is map out the next 60 days
and then mapping this out I want to map
out our time together
who's going to be taking care of our
four-year-old and who's not I what
projects do you have at work coming up
let's map this thing out because what
we're going to do is we're going to
start practicing building a life
together
okay okay and so what he's going to be
able to do is go cool I can do that I
can build a thing I can I can do a task
and when you say all right we have
mapped out
um Child Care we've mapped out I'm gonna
be taking time off of my job my
mother-in-law's coming in or my mom's
coming you'll be able to put all that on
the calendar and then you'll be able to
say we don't have any dates here
and by the way you're not gonna have any
dates for the first 60 days anyway
probably
well and I say that let me take that
back
some of my most amazing memories of my
life my whole life
is we got snowed in when my daughter was
born and we had a weird crazy snowstorm
and it snowed everybody in in Texas for
a week and my wife and I and our new
baby sat on a couch and we watched all
of the series Fringe because I loved
Pacey I love Josh what's his name Joshua
Jackson yeah Pacey because I live in the
Dawson's Creek fan we just watched the
whole thing and we had a fire going the
whole time and that was some of the most
intimate time of my life just holding my
baby sitting by my wife holding her hand
getting her getting up and getting
coffee whatever we needed to get and so
that was an awesome season but we
planned it too we were pretty
intentional about planning it so instead
of these uh it's gonna be no no we're
gonna have date time and it could be
date on the couch it could be date
watching TV I want to make sure we put
that on the calendar and what you're
doing is you're building in a language
between the two of you of intentionality
and then in three months or four months
when the fog starts lifting a little bit
and somebody can come over and keep your
little one for maybe two hours for
George to go to dinner or something like
that it will already be built into the
way y'all are talking and one of these
things might be from this point forward
um we're gonna do something every Sunday
night we're gonna get together and talk
every Sunday night we're gonna go for a
walk every Saturday morning whatever
that looks like see what I'm saying
yeah we're gonna build those things in
now I want to answer your your original
question and not just blow it off for a
second okay
um I want to give you a framework just
using can I just use my life I know
that's annoying because we're different
people but that's the guy I know the
best here's a framework
um that I'll pass along for how do you
share experiences when one of you likes
doing one thing and one of you likes
doing the other thing
um so I love music I love live music I
love I love lit laying my floor with
great headphones and just close them
eyes and turn the lights off and they're
listening to all the pieces I like
listening to the hi-hat and how they mix
the drums I just kind of can geek out on
it I also like playing music a lot also
and I love chaotic punk rock and heavy
metal and I love great singer
songwriters and folk singers and I love
hip-hop and I love stand-up comedy so I
love the whole Arc and so if I look step
back and look I like noise and I like a
little bit of chaos and I like art
performed and I like being in a crowded
space with people who are all have our
eyes headed in the same direction and
we're sharing music we're laughing doing
all the stuff together okay my wife also
likes music
she likes it at a reasonable volume in a
car and she doesn't mind What song comes
next on the radio usually and she has
curated playlists I don't I wouldn't
know how to make a playlist I know how
to make a mixtape I was a gangster
mixtape but I don't know how to make a
playlist
um and so the last month I went and saw
a band called White Reaper at a tiny
little Club they were Mayhem it was
super fun I went and saw under oath at
another club and they were like
screaming and ah and it was just chaos
and then my wife and I went to the Ryman
Auditorium and watched a folk band that
a folk rock band that we both have loved
for 25 years
and
um I've got a show coming up like I'm
playing guitar on this thing and it was
a guitar part that I've been trying to
learn for a long time so I'm down in the
basement playing and playing and playing
she would probably rather set her
eyelids on fire than sit in a watch me
practice guitar
but I had a moment I had like a little
breakthrough and like a teenager I ran
upstairs and was like hey you can listen
to this and I played it and she smiled
so big and she was not smiling because
her husband was going weedily diddly on
the guitar she was smiling because she
saw how happy I was that I accomplished
something right
right and she's into gardening and I
like being outside I don't understand
all the gardening things she's doing and
reading she's a great she's a way better
writer than me and she's a coach all I
had to say is this the distance we
create inside our togetherness
gives us intimacy and new avenues to get
to know each other
okay so I want you to think of you and
your husband as that ring that you wear
on your finger y'all are bound together
where can you create
pockets of I didn't know that about you
tell me more what are you learning wow I
didn't know you could do that inside of
that Circle
and so what I would tell you is
have your own things and be really good
at them and then share them
on occasion and vice versa and sometimes
you just got to put on headphones and go
to the monster truck rally or whatever
the thing is and my wife has gone to one
or two punk shows and she sits up
against the wall and during the chaos
and she just Smiles because she's like
what are these guys doing they're just
morons and I've gone to my fair share of
country music Hee-Haw whatever George
Strait came in on a horse once that's
all I know and I was there for that so
sometimes you just take one for the team
you enjoy it because you're in love with
the person and you and you love seeing
them that happy
but this idea that we all have to do the
same thing together all the time that's
just a recipe for this is going to be a
disaster and my wife and I have I've
been guilty especially of
being too disengaged from what she's
doing so there's a balance there you see
what I'm saying
yeah but you feel free to go down the
rabbit part of the problem that I think
that we've had because like I come from
the background of you at least you know
you put the phone down and you try to
participate and you try to
you know you try to enjoy what's in
front of you as best as you're able
because you don't want to feel like
you're dragging the other person down
whereas sometimes I think my husband if
we go out and do something that I enjoy
doing it almost turns into a
like he should just get credit for going
with me and if he wanted to sit on his
phone during the you know whatever it
was that that should be acceptable and
I'm like and if I'm honest I'm like that
like that hurts me that hurts my
feelings because I just want him to kind
of be present with me in the moment
you've got to say those words
because what you're asking him to do is
to be a mind reader
because he would probably rather have
explosive diarrhea than go to a knitting
event or I don't I'm just making
something up awful
um or to a 4-H event or whatever thing
you're into in Bryan College Station
and so he's gonna go and he thinks he's
making a great sacrifice
on behalf of mankind he's not going to
be one of those husbands that just stays
at home and drinks drinks crummy beer
he's going to go with his wife and thank
God for cell phones
right and you've got to take the extra
step and say Here's when we go to these
things I would love it it means a lot to
me if you're present
if you're here with me
and I don't think that the whole world
is about dropping if my wife asked me to
watch golf
like I'm huge like if she said I'm a
huge golf fan all of a sudden well I
don't know if we'd stay married if that
happened but it would be close but if
she said oh we're just gonna I just want
you to spend seven hours watching golf
with me I would have to say I can't do
that
if you want me to come down like when it
gets really awesome then I will come
give you this much time I will put my
phone down and I'll plug in you can tell
me all about golf
um but that'd be tough for me because I
don't like watching golfing it's it's um
I think it's an Abomination and it's
it's insane
all my friends are golfers so you see
what I'm saying I think you're putting a
ton of pressure on yourself and you're
expecting your husband to be a mind
reader don't do that okay okay let me
end the call with this
your needs are worth being spoken
clearly and out loud
and it sounds like what you're doing is
you're hedging your bets because you
don't want to run this guy off
or you don't want to be annoying or you
don't want to be a burden and you don't
want to be in the way
so as a husband from close to where you
all are right now
with two little kids
I will implore you almost beg you
be very clear about what you need and
give him an opportunity to show up
and he's gonna mess it up
and you are too
and part of your marriage is going to be
not with everything being perfect but
it's as Esther Pearl says it's the
repair part how do we come back together
after I missed it I showed up to the
event and I was on my phone the whole
time and you felt completely
disconnected and I thought I was being
husband of the year how do we solve that
problem with back to what I said earlier
we're gonna have these Sunday night
get-togethers We're not gonna have a
fight on the way home I'm not gonna mope
and be like oh you didn't show I'm not
gonna do that I'm gonna recognize when I
wasn't clear and then on Sunday night
when we get together and say Hey you
came to this thing I'm really grateful
you came
I know you're not into heavy metal music
or into calf roping or whatever is going
on
I know that
but it would mean the world to me it was
important that you came but you weren't
with me when you come I want you with me
I'd rather you not come then come and
just sit there on your phone the whole
time and we're going to do that on the
Sunday night meetings when there's no
there's not a lot of energy in those
meetings those are planning meetings
those are fun meetings where we're
dreaming about what our life's gonna be
and we're trying to figure out how to
get there it's not going to be in the
Heat of the Moment it's not gonna be
accusations
all that said good luck on having your
baby
give yourself tons of Grace give him
some clear directions Kelly I I may need
to get Sheila printed a list for me all
the way from things I'm not allowed to
say in the delivery room questions I'm
not allowed to ask and things that were
going to be she needed for me in the
next week it was so amazing it was such
a gift so great I may get that and we'll
just put that the show notes that is
like a template for other families that
sounds I would love to see that
you would die laughing because it's
exactly tailored to me yes it's awesome